[Música]
sus seguidores lo catalogan como un acto
de guerra por lo que se manifestaron en
el estado de Florida para expresarle su
apoyo justo antes de que compadezca ante
un tribunal de Miami tras ser imputado
en un caso de documentos clasificados
una cita que tendrá lugar un día antes
de que cumpla 77 años
y toda la vida me he vestido de Trump
con mucho orgullo me han tirado piedra
me han tirado botellas
me han tirado carro arriba aquí todos me
conocen Yo siempre me he vestido de
Trump y con mucho orgullo el 9 de junio
del departamento de Justicia dio a
conocer la imputación de 37 cargos
federales contra el expresidente con los
que Argumenta arriesgó la seguridad
nacional la acusación venía acompañada
de estas fotografías donde se pueden ver
cajas con documentos clasificados en
distintas partes de su residencia de
Mara lago en Florida y de su club de
golf en Nueva Jersey la acusación
también asegura que Trump recibió miles
de invitados en más de 150 eventos
durante el tiempo que los documentos
estuvieron allí
durante una convención del partido de
republicano en Georgia el fin de semana
Trump aseguró que se trata de una
estrategia para debilitar su imagen en
las elecciones presidenciales de 2024 a
las cuales ya anunció su postulación
la acusación ridícula E infundada contra
mí por parte del departamento de
injusticia fabricada por la
administración biden quedará registrada
como uno de los abusos de poder más
horribles en la historia de nuestro país
está tratando de encarcelar a su
principal oponente político un oponente
que le está ganando por mucho en las
encuestas la acusación al expresidente
por cargos federales no tiene
precedentes en la historia de Estados
Unidos siendo conspiración y obstrucción
de la Justicia dos de los más graves